the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler welcome back to the honeydew
with y'all y'all we're over here doing
it in the night pants studios i'm ryan
sickler i want to say thank you for your
support
i'm very excited if you don't know you
get the honeydew a day early audio and
video that's on a monday ad free at no
additional cost for the rest of the year
if you sign up for a year you get a
month free all right it's a good 2021.
um i love seeing this community continue
to grow we're flooded with emails and
please keep them coming we're going
through all of them i want to eventually
i'd love to do an episode with every
single one of you we're not half-assing
it over here i'm not doing some
20-minute abbreviated episode i'm doing
the real deal with you guys i love
talking to you i love my [ __ ] job and
we're over here highlighting the
lowlights with y'all today
um
very excited to have a guest on here
first time we've even talked about this
subject we're going to be talking about
today ladies and gentlemen please
welcome michael farahani welcome to the
honeydew with y'all michael farahani
thank you ryan it's a pleasure to be
here pleasure to scare you i appreciate
you saying that yeah i mean we'll give a
little um no pun intended tip off of the
episode um we're gonna be talking about
your priapism and the surgery
that led and you said um i have a
picture i could just send it and i was
like yeah you know maybe we'll put a
little not safe for work when we put it
in your post and then the [ __ ] thing
downloaded on my phone and popped open
and i was like holy [ __ ]
ash and i were not expecting to see that
[ __ ] bloodbath
no it is man oh man so real quick uh
michael where are you right now
i'm in santa ana right next to the zoo 5
and 55 socal okay and um how old are you
i'm 35 years old all right michael what
do you do for a living
i'm a construction inspector i work for
an engineering firm i go to job sites
and i
make people hate me by telling them
their work is wrong sampling concrete
asphalt compaction testing on soil all
that kind of stuff they're building a uh
like a four-story condo right behind my
unit right now are you the guy that
comes in and tells them whether their
shit's [ __ ] up or not is that the kind
of stuff are you just business yeah no
that's me residential too
well we do mostly schools my company uh
public works schools uh anything that's
funded by government money airports
gotcha though but i've done residential
with other companies now okay
um so let's talk about this priapism
let's talk about how it happened
uh because
your email says what five times it
[ __ ] happened to you five times
ultimately resulting in me requiring
surgery to fix it so
in case people don't know what priapism
is please explain uh the uh
definition and how long you have your
erection too just curious yeah so
priapism is
like on a viagra cialis commercial they
say you know if you have an erection for
more than four hours seek medical
treatment
um there's two types of prioritism
there's one that's called low flow and
high flow low flow is ischemic that
means the blood gets in doesn't come
back out and it's just constantly trying
to push it in there the high flow is
less dangerous and you can usually go
home and take care of it on your own you
know what i mean right um because the
blood is circulating so nothing's
getting trapped in there it's not
getting uh necrotic or you know losing
oxygen
so
okay um let's start at the beginning
i didn't take any of those kind of pills
i took a prescription from my doctor
okay so wait uh sorry i am going to
interrupt you there so this is not an ed
pill that you took to get this
no i don't have that problem at all
it's just so
yeah um i was having problems sleeping
went to my doctor and they go through a
whole battery of stuff before you uh
they prescribe you anything that can be
potentially habit-forming and i have a
history of addiction in my family and
myself so they they really want to
make you try everything before they give
you something like ambien or whatever so
they gave me a medication called
trazadone
um
i had never heard of it until this point
and
they didn't even mention that this could
have been one of the side effects of
this turns out one in 15 000 men have
this as a side effect and i am the
statistic
you're the one
i'm the one in fifteen thousand damn
so i took it the first night and nothing
happened didn't help me sleep only 50
milligrams very small amount and they're
like okay if that doesn't work double it
take a hundred so i did that and i wake
up real early for work like four o'clock
in the morning because i got to be on
job sites at like 6 30 and far away
wake up and i'm a pr okay we're gonna
have to get this out of the way there's
gonna be a lot of medical talk a lot of
talk about the penis anatomy if that
stuff is squeamish to you or your
listeners maybe tune this one out
because it's gonna get screamish to me
i'm not gonna shoot it out or else this
episode's over so i'm
gonna i'm gonna grin and bear it over
here all right all right um so yeah
naturally i'm one of those dudes who
always wakes up with morning wood yeah
it just is what it is they say it's
healthy too by the way when you wake up
with a butter it's supposed to be that
yeah your blood circulating properly and
all that right
so wake up normal thing you know go to
the bathroom that usually makes it go
away you know yeah it leaves the
pressure um doesn't do the trick
take a shower doesn't do the trick so
hold on your dick still hard you've
pissed
it's still did you have to try to sit
down and force it into the under the lid
yes i did for the number two
i've been there so many times yeah
leaning forward
it's spraying back all over the head of
your dick you're like god damn it yep
that's that's exactly what we're talking
about so you pee it doesn't go down i
can go down you step in the shower
you're showering this thing's still at
this point it usually is yes it's down
at this point it's rock hard rock hard
is it painful
no not yet just a normal erection right
now okay normal
so i get out of the shower go back to my
room i have a little bit of time so do
you have a girlfriend or a wife or
no not right now singing okay so one day
i have to take care of it myself yeah i
was gonna say you couldn't be like get
the [ __ ] over here let's let's use this
okay i wish i yeah
but no it was just me so i do the usual
doesn't go down no way wait did you did
you orgasm oh yeah okay and it didn't go
down after that didn't go down this is
like a 17 year old magic dick that's
what this thing is
yes i i tell people even naturally like
i have the opposite of ed
it's i can be you blow on my arm this is
ready to go
okay i guess but not in the normal sense
yeah right
um
now i'm like trying to get ready for
work trying to put on my pants and lace
up my steel toe boots and it's like
come on man what are you doing
try the usual again squeeze one more out
before i leave damn good for you bro you
got two out of the chamber before you
bounced yeah that's impressive i'm sorry
oh shut up okay
um yeah so and that doesn't do it no it
doesn't do it and are you thinking
anything do you think right away this
[ __ ] medications [ __ ] with me it's
the only new thing in your body no no
not at all because they at the time they
prescribed it they didn't mention that
this could be one of the side effects
you know it's like oh it could make you
drowsy like yeah that's the point that's
what i want i want to sleep you want to
sleep
so drive to the office um i'm working
with somebody that day and i'm tall
you could tell i'm a big guy so you know
i have a stomach and my shirt hangs over
so i gotta hide it pretty well no tuck
it that you know it's not like i ain't
no uh skinny kid with uh
tight jeans that it's gonna you know
print out
um
so i go i'm working with this guy we
have to go out to some uh freshly paved
street and take four samples
working hard big so hard right now
i mean we're gonna fast forward to 11
p.m it's still hard gotta dig hard out
in the street like these double yellow
lines are all crooked man your dick's
all straight line it up with my dick
line this painting with my dick
oh my god
so wearing um i wear a carhartt like uh
construction worker pants i got a car
t-shirt next door i got one they're
yeah they're made of canvas the pants
they're very heavy duty like fire hose
material almost so there's no give
and it's just pressed up against the
front of my pants the whole day now it's
starting to get sore we're at like noon
so we're six hours later six hour
erection right now
and it's just
it's just beating against your zipper
all day yes all day okay
i'm standing around like i have back
pain trying to like arch my back and
just you know take the pressure off
um
so we finished we finished up our work
for the day
and uh
luckily the guy i was working with was
nice enough to take our equipment back
to the office i go straight home
instantly get on my computer start
googling everything you don't rub one
out when you get home
i try after my second shower one more
time
we'll go in order
google everything look up the medication
holy [ __ ] this is a possible side effect
and now it's starting to click with me
i'm like oh no and so the next thing you
do is look up how do you take care of
this [ __ ] at home because i don't want
anybody to know oh yeah
yeah so it's um
ice it
take a cold shower take a hot shower
meditate relax try the usual one more
time those are all things that make me
hard
whatever those are all things that make
me hard maybe not the cold shower i have
like a bag of ice on it and it's
so
we're gonna pause for just a second to
talk about the anatomy and what's
happening here
um can i let me ask you this though is
it just your dick that's hurting or your
balls hurting too
just the dick okay just the dick the
balls are good they're just chilling all
right yeah
and by the way the pain is
it's hard to describe like a headache
feels one way a toothache feels a
different way a muscle leg feels
different this feels like if you were
pushing out your cheeks like
as hard as you can and you start to get
that and then like more air and like
someone has a bike pump in your mouth
and you're like my cheeks are gonna pop
that's what it feels like down there
it's just pressure i got to ask you did
you take a picture of it um because i'm
imagining it's as big as it's ever been
in your whole goddamn life
[Laughter]
i'd measure it
through the series of these happenings i
mean i have pictures of it standing
majestically and then i have pictures of
it black and blue
the size of a poke can oh my god dude
this is after the needles like the next
day after the picture you saw i looked
down and it looked like a diet pepsi can
with the black and blue and stuff you
don't have you have one proud picture
though right before it all went to hell
where you're like look at this
that's the one that goes that i send out
to tinder one on the wall right
exactly oh yeah that's my dick right
there yes
right next to my children i'm a man all
right
i would have molded it i would have got
everything like no no that's my dick
that's my is that tommy lee's dick on
your on your fireplace
no not tommy lee i would call myself
extra medium
all right
so um just for the listeners uh the
anatomy of it real quick everybody's oh
the penis is not a muscle there's no
muscles in it whatsoever it's an organ
it has glands the only way that you know
guys can make it jump around is just a
little suspensory ligament on top
we can't control it like an elephant
trunk you know it's not a muscle yeah i
know i have one
there we go
um i know naturally naturally it's
actually in a constricted state you have
little spiral blood vessels that go up
to the the sides of it and it's always
you know when you're laying there and
your dick's hard and and your pulse is
just it's just bouncing lightly to your
your heartbeat
is your dick just going like crazy like
is it is it
like just bang bang bang like is your
hair no not really it's pretty still
it's just hard
yeah once i got to the hospital and the
anxiety started then yeah every
heartbeat i could feel down there just
like if you had a smash finger you could
yeah yeah
it's like that yeah
so when you get an erection it's your
penis actually relaxing
and the blood vessels opening and
allowing blood to flow in so the
opposite of what people think yeah
um
so this plays into the medication they
give you once you get there and so now
we're talking it's like 2 or 3 p.m it's
been almost 12 hours and i'm you look at
stories of like oh this guy had a
24-hour one they had to amputate that
[ __ ]
i'm like no
oh that happens they cut the dick off
some people it gets necrose and
they're so embarrassed and they think
it's going to go away because the
problem is the trapped blood has no
oxygen it's like a dead limb it's like a
tourniquet that's exactly what it is
it's a tourniquet on your dick you're
killing your dick
you're killing it how do they cut your
dick where do they cut it off like at
the dick root like what do they do what
do you have yes oh my god this is
terrifying pee like a girl for the rest
of your life
holy i would still stand
they have prosthetics and stuff in
implants and i had to have that
conversation with the doctor before my
surgery i'm like all right
we're jumping ahead yeah
so uh i go to the er
and
i have a i'm holding my backpack in
front of me in front of me i'm wearing
basketball
on it
[Laughter]
oh man
um and the worst part is like you walk
up to the counter and they're like okay
what brings you here today and there's
like where's my anonym where's my
confidential there's like ladies
standing next to me so i write it on a
post and i slide it to her and they're
nurses behind the counter and she's like
how long has your dick been hard
that would have been more fun though
yeah right once they see what that
problem is
they know how serious that is all the
people in the waiting room they're like
you don't even sit down go straight to
the back
go to the back take my blood pressure
pick blood all that kind of stuff run
all the tests and then they have to
examine you
and it was a woman doctor and her female
med student
i'm like i explained it's i'm so
embarrassed my face is red i can't even
i just can't and i i lay back i don't
even look i just pull down the
basketball shorts pull down the boxers
the doctor's like
okay but the med student's like oh no
yeah
it's scary
yeah it's scared
of starbucks right now oh
you scared her out of the profession i
don't
i don't know if maybe she thought it was
like a joke and like no he's not coming
because describe what she saw what are
we looking at now when you're finally
back there and they're looking at it
what does this thing look like so this
is really
okay um
it's
not really starting to get black and
blue yet it's just starting to get dark
because the blood in there is
deoxygenated and the weird part is like
you know when you flex it you can like
force a little blood into the head
one of one of the hallmarks of this is
your head is completely deflated and
like like white like a piece of paper
there's no blood in there what so the
shaft is hard but the head is like a
shaft it's like all wrinkly like it's
been in a pool all day
yeah yeah if you ever see like a medical
cross-section of a penis it's basically
like two tubes with your urethra on the
bottom and it's like it's like two um
balloon animal balloons you know that's
that's the easiest way to mentally look
at that okay and they they they push
around it like on the like on the base
like does it hurt here what's going on
any pain in the testicles like you asked
no no no
okay and then they tell me something i
didn't
quite believe like okay this isn't that
bad yet and i'm like what
and like we're gonna try a couple of
first they inject stuff into it instead
of pulling out hold on hold don't just
jump into injecting [ __ ] in dicks cause
that means needles now
are they going in the side where your
vein is or they're going down your
urethra and i don't know why i'm asking
but i'm asking my legs are shaking
[Laughter]
ten and ten and two or like nine and
three in the sides oh two of them
well
in the beginning it's one because they
say that the two sides the two corporate
cabernosa and all the medical term they
communicate with each other if you drain
one it gives a place for that other side
to finally flow out so they start with
one
and
they numb you for i mean i feel like you
i feel like i'd be able to take that if
your dick's that [ __ ] hard like that
i feel like you'd be able to take that
the the amount of nerve endings
they numb it with like this freezing
spray first
um they don't numb it with like
novocaine or lidocaine or anything like
that yet
um
and what they inject
surprised me it's sudafed
it's phenylephrine pseudofed pe that's
phenylephrine it's a vasoconstrictor
they try to inject something in there to
close those blood vessels down and force
that blood out
um now the part that scared me was when
the emergency room doctor came she's
like well
i've never done one of these before but
i've read the literature
you read the book late
well then go practice on someone else's
dick god damn it
you're her case zero zero one yeah no
thanks
and they ask you all like what did you
take this and that you know well you're
not african-american you don't have
sickle cell anemia
a lot of black guys get this because of
the anemia because they're anyway um so
they she injects it just subcutaneously
she misses the actual now just under the
skin and now there's like a bubble like
the size of a grape of this medicine
looks like i have a giant wart
[Laughter]
[Music]
you missed it
um she tries a couple times and they do
it like every five minutes and they they
monitor your blood pressure because it
doesn't just affect you down there too
much vasoconstrictor can really like
spike your blood pressure so they're
constantly checking that and if that
gets too high they're forced to
go the opposite route and suck the blood
out they call it aspiration
so she does this for about an hour every
five minutes i get a new injection but
she actually hits the glands this time
the
court
every five minutes
yeah
every dozen a dozen shots in your dick
to try to get this thing down
yeah both sides oh um
yeah
eventually but here's the
all because you wanted to [ __ ] sleep
not because you wanted to get laid not
because you're out there popping these
things oh man some kind of playboy oh
cause she wanted a good night's sleep
yeah
yeah
man i'm sorry dude okay go ahead so now
you've got a dozen needles in your dick
does that grape thing still sitting
there does that eventually drain that
eventually like absorbs into it here
so she's like okay um we're getting to a
point where there's nothing more that a
general doctor can do we need a
specialist you gotta call urologist
well there's not one here on call at the
hospital we got a patient from home so
you're going to be hanging tight for
about 40 minutes as he drives here i'm
like [ __ ]
great they page two
they come in as a team they've done this
a million times i learn and they both
attack it one side of the other and they
start by numbing you
uh they inject around the base kills all
the nerve endings and then they go like
at the top way deep down they call it a
full penile block
it was incredibly painful for about 30
seconds and then in your urethra no no
at the base of your dick
like if i'm looking straight down right
at the bay and they go needle in like
they're trying to hit your pelvis
[ __ ] yeah numb the whole [ __ ]
and
so after about 30 seconds i'm just like
my arms are sore i'm white knuckling the
hospital bed so hard i'm like oh you
know the pain is unreal and then it's
gone
and then i realized oh i had they put an
iv in me and the pain went away because
right into the vein and that's my first
experience and probably only experience
with what some sort of iv drug user
would have because i i listen to you a
lot and i react like you to opiates i
get itchy
grow up yeah i
knock on wood i will never be a failhead
but when that thing hits your vein it
goes down to your toes up to your head
it's just like boom it's like you got
shot like a little lightning bolt hits
you and it's like
ah so they start going to work
and what are they doing what do you know
or are you just out
yes uh i'm aware i'm not looking yeah
that's what i mean that's what i mean i
didn't mean i know you're not knocked
out yeah are you i i don't know if i
could watch that they they tell me like
don't move because
if you ever get like a hernia or you
like pull your groin or something you
realize like every little movement you
make affects your core muscles and all
the way down there so i'd like lean
forward and
in unison they're like don't move so i
just lay back and let them work on me
the reason that picture is so gnarly is
that their surgery that's what i wanted
to ask you yeah so this is their
aftermath
the reason that picture is so gnarly is
i didn't realize at the time they're not
capturing the blood anywhere the little
tip of the needle they put in the
syringe there's no syringe they just put
those needles in and just let it drain
and it's just going off it's just going
all over my tube or anything it's just
spraying out
no it's yeah it's first it sprays and
then it just drips like a like a faucet
that will drip drip drip drip
um they capture some but it's
it's a brutal pick we're gonna include
it in your post and we'll cut we'll put
not safe for work but it is
ash is there a way to like uh cover it
so people don't just
roll up on it
make it blurry first and then they have
to click on it to clear it up or
something can we do that ash
yeah okay we so they're not capturing
the blood and that here's the problem
it's not staying down
um
they they completely drain it and they
they literally squeeze the blood out
they're grabbing the needles are way at
the bottom
so they're grabbing the top and just
squeezing the blood out
then they let go and i can feel it just
right back up
wait they drained all that blood out and
your dick still went up how where's the
blood coming from that that's pumping it
in there
the the the blood vessels just aren't
constricting enough and it's just
they're just wide open like a fire hose
allowing blood to come right back in so
they start
simultaneously aspirating the blood out
and injecting the phenylephrine in
and finally they're like
i'm like can i have some water i'm dying
here and they're like we can't even give
you water because
you might need surgery and if you're
under general anesthesia anything in
your stomach you'll you have a potential
to throw up
so i'm
finally they're like okay
oh and simultaneously they have to flush
it out so they're injecting saline into
it
and it's crazy like how many [ __ ]
needles are we talking about in this
procedure dozens it sounds like dozens
50 60 sticks oh my god
you had 50 or 60 needles stuck in your
dick to drain blood
and it didn't work
so
the picture you see is me finally down
that's why there's only like this much
of me sticking up through all the papers
and stuff all that blood around because
they're not capturing it and they say
we're gonna leave you here don't touch
it it's a sterile field and i don't even
want to pick up so that's why the
picture is from that angle all i do is
take my phone go like this
oh my god and i freaked myself out i've
seen it so many times and it's happened
to me so many times now that you know
that doesn't freak me out anymore but
i was having a pat almost having a panic
attack at that point they gave me um
valium to calm me down because yeah
spike i would feel like oh my god i'm
gonna lose my dick i'm i'm already
thinking about the [ __ ] doctor that
said double up on this [ __ ] because it's
just what it's easy math like any
[ __ ] [ __ ] could be like well if one
didn't work maybe two does
yeah i
so do you do you do you tell them you're
on this medication and they're like okay
this is what caused it and all that they
know this okay yes so they leave you
alone and now what happens
it's it stays down
okay it does
um now you saw all that blood that
wasn't just on those top things it's
running down my legs it's on my ass it's
in the under it's on my shorts i can't
believe that much blood is in a dick
well not all at once fills up drain it
fills up drain it fills up drainage
so and it's just dripping out like a
faucet so it's like an open wood it's
like a cut
um
i have to clean myself up
a nurse comes and brings me warm wet
towels wait they're not cleaning
yourself i just butchered your dick and
you got to wipe yourself up yep oh man
this was moving over where you went
whatever they got your dick down they
got you got it they got it down um so
that's time number one the next day i
woke up like i said black and blue size
of a coke can just about wait the next
day after the surgery
no this is after the very first
cryptism you were good wake up it's
still swollen i took photos
i see it's
not hard it's swollen it's not a wreck
the skin around it
um and it was that big like a pepsi can
it was just small oh my god yeah please
tell me you took a picture
uh it's not on this phone i i wouldn't
nick looked like a soda can i'd be
taking pictures and texted everybody no
but it looks everywhere it's black blue
red it's it's it's it's nasty it's a
solid man i want antibiotics because you
know all that kind of stuff
and eventually i heal everything goes
okay um
i'm still seeing a psychiatrist and i
it's depression like we can get into
some of the other stuff later they put
me on wellbutrin
and
a couple weeks into taking wellbutrin it
happens again no way
and by this time i'm actually seeing a
my personal urologist because i have one
now they assigned me one he's a rock
star doctor by the way he works for the
mayo clinic and the surgery i had is
like an experimental thing the only like
12 dudes have had this surgery that i
had the one they
did so
in an instance where
so the second time uh was actually much
more standard because i recognized the
signs and i went way earlier this first
one we finished it it was like 7 or 8
p.m from 4 a.m it's like 14 hours holy
[ __ ] to get your dick down
how many days were you hard before you
finally had the surgery again what was
the total amount of days
oh every time that
so the five times that this happened to
me no i just mean that very first one
how many days were you hard before you
finally it was that it was that day it
was all one day so it was all those
hours that you were hard and you were
like [ __ ] this okay
there are people who apparently like
wait two or three days before they get
seen and they're the ones who have
you know oh
okay so then you go
immediately
i go immediately
the standard treatment works they pull
one or two syringes of blood out they
put a little bit of the sudafed
phenylephrine in there stays down
like cool everything's okay and my
urologist is like
your [ __ ] psychiatrist
he pulls out a list he didn't prepare
this just for me he's like people who
are prone to priapisms
don't take viagra cialis blah blah blah
well butrin why are they giving this to
you i'm like
i don't know i talked to the
psychiatrist and they're like that's not
a reaction
the urologist whose specialty this says
it is and i got a reaction so i'm not
taking this anymore
fast forward a year
i'm good for a year
like may 24th of last year i was looking
at those photos on my phone just a few
minutes i'm wearing a mask this is
during the pandemic this happened to me
recently i'm chewing dentine gum next
thing i know my dick's rock hard
i feel like everything makes your
[ __ ] dick on it
what's the next [ __ ] that's gonna ruin
your dick uh apparently after this first
the very first time it happened from the
trasodon it just like it made me
susceptible to future events no way it
like so these it like plants a seed in
you so to speak jesus christ christ so
after the first two the problems about
the [ __ ] medications you want one
thing and then it causes 19 other side
effects on this [ __ ] yes all you wanted
to do was sleep
from that's the beginning
um at work you know and the the this
first one of the second batch we're on
number three now
happens very much like the very first
one i had woke up rock hard did all that
other stuff even went to work that day
because i've learned that
from then on from those first two
i would regularly wake up with morning
wood and it would it would go away on
its own by about noon or one damn so you
would have an erection from you said you
might get up early eight hours
yeah an eight-hour erection most of the
morning after those two instances yeah
so so i keep i have here in my desk a
whole bunch of uh you can take sudafed
orally and it helps it
so i take instead of like one of those
little red pills that take like three or
four they'd say take a high dose and
then after a few hours if it doesn't go
down then seek treatment
so i would do that
no joke ryan once a week i'd have to do
that
um and it turns out
there so the reason guy a lot of guys
get pee boners like morning wood and
then you peed it goes away is your full
bladder
expands inside you and pushes on the
inside of your spine and hits your
sacral nerve and when you pee it
relieves that pressure and then it goes
down look at you later on my own dick
well [ __ ] this i'm i'm an expert on this
because i've researched the [ __ ] out of
it
a full bladder can do that full bowels
can do that so like go number one go
number two take a laxative empty
everything out take take your uh
pseudofed and
pray
that's basically it
so this
this third one gnarly back to the uh
real quick what made this what
medication are you taking now on this
third one is it a different meds or
still the wellbutrin no there's nothing
now i'm not taking anything just
happened
so when it happens spontaneously and for
no reason they call it idiopathic so
this is idiopathic ischemic priapism
they don't know literally they have no
idea and so i see i go to the doctor
they do the thing
pretty brutal it's like halfway between
the first and second a lot of blood you
know all that stuff
go home
two days later so this is the 24th like
now the 26th or 27th happens again
and this one is in the i was in insane
pain the first time and i told him like
look
i know what's about to happen to me i'm
about to have a panic attack i don't
care
can you sedate me for this and just do
whatever you want
and they're like we don't want to put
you out fully so they did what's called
a twilight sedation they gave me
propofol the knockout juice they put me
to a trauma room but they gave me just
enough to keep me awake enough to like
answer questions and stuff and there's a
timer on that they're like 20 minutes
either 20 minutes we have to fully knock
you out or we have to stop pushing the
meds
so i ask you at this point now we're
talking like if this is the fourth
proceed we're talking probably hundreds
of needles in your dick at this point
now
unfortunately i mean are you just
[ __ ]
i don't want to say getting used to it
but is it getting easier each time i
mean
or is it getting better each time
because now you've got the knowledge the
20 20 hindsight and you're getting there
quicker and [ __ ] like that get in there
quicker and i know but still you're
getting needles there's no way around
that there's nothing they can give you
earlier on where they don't have to use
a needle to drain or whatever
there's there's really nothing oral that
can that sudafed won't do it if you get
it early enough
well i took so much i took so much that
fourth time that they couldn't even try
injecting it into me because my blood
pressure was so high from all the vaso
oh god they're like look if that's not
going to do we got to go straight to
aspiration sorry so they sedate me and
like at minute 17 they do a crazy
numbing everywhere block so when they
stop giving me the propofol i'm numb
and they get it down it stays down
how long do you have to sit there and
before they decide whether it's going to
stay down or not
i have to stay there for four hours but
only two of those are for observations
for this
the other two is either you have to have
someone pick you up because we gave you
opiates or you wait four hours and then
you could drive yourself home okay i
drove myself home every time i drove
myself to the hospital every time
two days later it happens again god damn
two days
yeah this is like two or three it's like
june 2nd now from like may 24th to june
2nd we're on number five and you're
having to go in the hospitals during the
pandemic when people are [ __ ] dying
and [ __ ] i that's where i got my first
covet test when they now they give you
your own q-tip and you just go in this
is when they're like tickling your brain
and [ __ ] way too i'm sitting there
with the oxygen on my face for this
surgery and they're just standing around
chatting amongst themselves because they
can't start surgery until my covenant
test comes back negative
and it did so
now this experimental procedure this is
where we get a little bit more medical
on a normal case if it won't go down
through any other means they have to do
what's called a shunt
and this is where they go in through the
head of your dick they cut both sides
they put needles on top
can't they just hire a prostitute to
come in and bang you out and [ __ ]
relieve this thing
there's a piece of professional [ __ ]
hired by the government agencies at the
hospital professional [ __ ] that comes
in and gets these goddamn dicks down
stop shaming sex workers
getting caught up here um
so it's like
take a hot dog look it in the barrel put
two needles in it and oh my god for a
bit
they lit you could you google pictures
of a shot gonna do that definitely not
i'm just gonna listen to this episode so
they didn't do that to me they were
about to when i was awake they do this
while you're awake the shunt no and they
they put they put numbing cream on the
head of my dick they take me to a
special room and then all of a sudden my
this was a different urologist who was
on call
in comes my urologist and he's like ah
you're young i'm not doing this to you
here's your options so they did
something to me it sounds bad but it's
actually the better of two evils it's
called a pino scrotal decompression
so see now we're getting into my balls
and i don't like that at all yeah yes
not to scale because it's my finger but
finger you know dick balls
at the base where your balls meet the
shaft they cut like a smiley face thing
right there and they don't mess with
your balls or anything like that they
just open your scrotum your sack and
they they pretty much kind of do the
shunt procedure
but from the bottom and from the inside
so they don't have to mutilate the head
of your dick or anything like that and
they basically it's like unclogging a
drain they're going up through the base
at the like a just the balls up through
the base toward the top
yes they and it's it's roto-rooter they
go in there
they create space for the blood to come
out
and does it work
it works it works it works and
this is an experimental one you're
saying
it's new
there's bit you look at the medical
literature there's like 10 or 12
reported cases uh
with literature behind it and insane
success rates and you're one of them i'm
one of them
wow so you're in their early days of
literature and everything
yeah so that one i got to stay overnight
they put a catheter in me which is awful
god they're not leaving your dick alone
cather's bad
um
if you were in a serious relationship at
the time or just a sexual relationship
at the time what would they or do they
suggest like you're not going to be
having sex for six months eight months
what do they they put a time frame on
something like this
um like if you're married and what does
your wife have to do she gotta wait how
long well from the normal needles and
stuff as soon as the needle as soon as
you can handle it like the swelling and
pain goes away you're good to go and how
long did you say that was days weeks
the brutal ones like the first one on
the picture you saw we're talking like a
week or two that's it it feels fast to
me for something like the what i saw
there god well keep in mind don't jerk
off for two weeks
and you'll be getting erections all the
[ __ ] time so they tell you we need to
know if it still works are you in a
relationship try if you're single try by
yourself and report back later wait try
after it's healed or they want you to
actually try to get a nut out while it's
still
sore
if if you if you can
the pain to pleasure ratio has to be
high enough to where that you can come
despite the pain about as soon as that's
how i come though the pain is what makes
me calm
oh
the pain
i gotta have that balance mental pain
for me
[Laughter]
as soon as you can handle it i need all
the pains all the pains
so yeah
um after the surgery
i mean there's they have dissolvable
stitches in there and that's a lot of
pain and
does something else does urinating hurt
no actually not at all no
uh they're not messing with your urethra
it doesn't mess with your bladder
nothing like that
i learned recovering from this with
stitches and stuff
laying on my back i'm prone to them if i
i would feel myself start to get one
with stitches still in it's like a
lightning bolt going down your dick
hurts like hell
swing my legs over the bed and just sit
up
it drains out and it goes away so for
the first four or five days after the
surgery i slept in literally this chair
right here
i see i just was in my computer chair
lean back put my feet up blanket slept
um
and by the way
if you wait too long
and they can't salvage basically the
insides of your dick you get an implant
and there's a lot of dudes out there
that have it and there's different
technologies and
it's basically two inflatable tubes that
replace your corporate cavernosa and you
basically get what's a third ball in
your sack and you pump it right yeah
pump it up it goes up i saw an article i
just saw an article about this though
because is there a valve one too there's
some kind of like valve that maybe lets
it the blood in or whatever not blood
it's saline
yeah there's no blood that goes in um
it's a one-way valve and then once
you're done you squeeze it and you like
you reach it down there and you like
turn one thing and it allows it to come
back down um
so basically
yeah
that that was my saga with that and
that's uh that ties into all the other
[ __ ] that got me to this point why i
needed medication for sleep so i you
talked about addiction and things in
your past did all this dilaudid that
these painkillers did they put you back
on the wrong path or have you stayed um
clean and so
my only addiction well it starts with
food um i'm a big guy i'm a big guy now
but i was way i was like 430 pounds
where are you really how much are you
now
about 350. so i'm about 80 70 80 pounds
down i got down to all that dick blood
bro
that's all that dick blood you lost bro
oh my god
um
it's it's a it could be a three hour
episode just by my past but chaotic
upbringing went to eight different
schools before i went to high school
moved around 10 times constantly been
evicted
dad was i don't want to say dad was
intentionally abusive he was just very
angry that he couldn't provide for his
kids
i got the belt all the time he's a
ronnie and my mom is the irish one um
he was like a dictator if you said jump
he didn't want you to out loud
after this whole episode you just called
him a dictator
[Laughter]
an oppressive father um
so
did your parents stay together
they were married for 25 years but they
got divorced like 15 years ago
my dad's been remarried for a long time
and he's completely different by the way
i want to i want to say that i love my
dad i have a wonderful relationship with
him good once once he and my mom split
and he found basically the right person
for him his personality switched he's a
sweet old man pushover to the if i had a
bruise on my arm from like getting a
shovel handle at work if i tell him like
yeah i got a bruise he'd be like
are you are you okay do you need to sit
like i didn't get shot what is this
reaction
when he's the man who used to throw
plates against the wall and put his fist
through drywall and [ __ ] like that
me i have three sisters
excuse me we're all overweight nobody in
my family my dad's oldest is seven
nobody in my extended family has what
you would call a beach ready body
bad just bad genetics
um
i had always had body image issues and
once i left high school and i wasn't
forced to play sports all the time and
go to the tennis club with my dad i
immediately once i got a job in a car
every meal i ate came through my window
because my dad didn't want his kids to
get fat and food was like a punishment
which turned into my comfort
you you reach for a second scoop of rice
from he just looks at you like
uh you know that look that dad look like
don't you dare reach for that food
so food became my thing once i got out
from under his thumb i ballooned up to
350 400 whatever
fast forward to five six years ago um
my dad turned 60 i turned 30. this is
the first time he's brought up my weight
in maybe 12 years and he says look we
don't need to rehash this but
i'm 60 you're over 400 pounds there's
not a lot of cross over there you don't
see dudes walking around in their 60s
that big unless you do something about
this
you've already lived half your life that
that shook me
i tried dieting
all the diets and exercise i've gone
like this my entire life lose 50 pounds
gained 80 lose 100 gain 110.
he had weight loss surgery my mom did my
aunt did mostly successful so i'm like
look okay
let's go all in and
all of my life i was told that you lose
weight you'll start feeling better and
your depression will go away all this
kind of stuff had the surgery
rocketed down 150 pounds in a year
looking good look in the mirror realized
to myself
that wasn't it
i didn't it didn't change anything how
you felt i felt worse
wow it felt worse
this is where sleeping alcohol and stuff
comes i can see
i i've never been a big drinker
because i hate the taste of alcohol i i
enjoy the effect it has but like i think
all beer tastes like [ __ ] most mixed
like when i drink it would be good vodka
diluted crap with diet coke so you
couldn't even taste it
so i would just stay awake at night
hating myself this is before i got i did
this backwards i'm in therapy now i have
a good psychiatrist now and it's changed
my life but
before that i was just self-medicating
with food after you have the surgery you
can't do that anymore there's no more
binge eating my only coping mechanism is
gone
i can't eat till i'm stuffed and then
pass out in my bed so i just lay there
just staring at the ceiling like what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
well i know what gets me tired i have a
couple cocktails one or two i can't
drink carbonated beverages they don't
want it to expand your pouch so that's
why i started with vodka diet coke make
one or two and when you have the surgery
would you say that you said carbonated
uh water and any carbonated drinks
because they expand
it can expand the pouch they make so i
don't have a stomach
i just have a little pouch that goes
directly into my small intestines
and especially if you don't eat anything
there's nowhere for it to sit and um you
know slowly absorb it goes right into
your small intestines and one or two
drinks hits you like a freight train
immediately
and it's like okay i'm ready to sleep i
have just one or two drinks and then you
wake up the next morning you only had
one or two drinks you're not hungover
you feel fine
so that becomes very sustainable over
the course of a couple months one or two
a night turns into three or four after
about six months i wake up and look over
at my desk and it's like holy [ __ ] i
drank half a bottle of vodka last night
fast fast forward six months i'm killing
an entire bottle of tito's every night
damn with the two liter of diet a whole
bottle of tea so that's 17 or 18 drinks
and how do you i mean look i i stopped
drinking you know
i don't i'm not a drinker but i'll
certainly drink a beer have a shot
whatever but right i my tolerance is
high and um
just the amount of liquid in my stomach
would make me feel sick before i ever
got [ __ ] up yeah so you're talking
about 18 drinks just 18 glasses of water
i mean that would make me just feel like
[ __ ] just the heaviness of it that's why
honestly one of the things i love about
marijuana is um
you know it's just clean it's so i
remember my friends telling me that back
in the day it's way cleaner and less
sloppier than alcohol and i was like man
i get it i get it
yeah so and that was also i had to
because i hate the taste of it i deluded
the [ __ ] out of it so it was a bottle of
vodka and a two liter of diet coke every
night man every night
and um
i kept going to different doctors to try
and get different and all this time i'm
trying different antidepressant after
different antidepressant never cutting
out the alcohol
i'd stop for a week
you know i'm not a 30-year drinker who
has to wake up and i never drank her in
the morning never been pulled over never
got a dui it was always at night once i
was done with my day three or four pm
start to have a few and since i can't
drink a lot at once it would take me all
night to drink that much
it's like midnight i can finally go to
bed after starting drinking at 3 30 p.m
such a stupid way to live
go see a doctor
she prescribes me something she then
goes on maternity leave i can't get it
filled
my therapist sends me to a nurse
practitioner who's like a good advocate
for his patients he's like look i can
prescribe this for you just i want you
to get checked out first so i go to this
place turns out it was a rehab facility
and they didn't tell me
they they check me in they do they take
my blood they do all the stuff i'm like
yeah i haven't even drank in two days
i'm trying to get better but they're
like
no uh this was a detox facility not
rehab i did rehab once i've been detoxed
a few times
um
i'm like well i didn't sign up for this
i thought i was just getting like a
little physical they're like
am i being held here like no you're not
being held here but you've already been
admitted so if you leave it's going to
be against medical advice and your
insurance isn't going to cover it and
you're already thousands of dollars in
man that's [ __ ] up
so i get the like we're ready to go to
the fourth floor i'm like what's the
fourth floor like that's detox so
i was so pissed off after that i mean i
felt good i was clean after that i mean
they give you medicine and you feel good
but i wasn't ready for that and it
wasn't my choice i almost immediately
relapsed
um
kept drinking this goes on and on a
couple more trips to the doctor good and
i i would never miss work because of it
um the first time i actually felt
withdrawal symptoms was i had to work
overnight
so i couldn't drink
so i didn't i went to work
started getting heart palpitations
around 11 pm because my body's needing
the alcohol
finally i
talked to my site my therapist first and
i'm like
i i'm getting close to hitting rock
bottom and i don't want to what do we do
i've only been drinking for like two and
a half years
i'm not like a lifelong alcoholic liver
is fine no problems they've done the
ends everything is great
they're like go to rehab
start with detox
you have the best insurance go to hogue
and i went to the hog hospital checked
myself in
did the six day uh
detox did they keep you there because
coming off of alcohol can kill you
is that right
it's one of the few alcohol and benzos
like if you are a hardcore xanax addict
and you instantly stop it could kill you
because what it does is it's a central
nervous system
depressant
and if you're constantly getting loaded
what your body does is like okay well
we're going to be this way all the time
it increases your neurotransmitters and
gaba receptors and stuff to counteract
it that's what is your tolerance so you
need more and more and more to squash
all those transmitters and finally
depress yourself enough to sleep
rip all that away all of a sudden your
brain is literally firing and fast
forward that's why people get shaky they
get nervous and
you can get what's called the dts
delirium tremens where you start to
hallucinate and dive a heart attack it's
so they they give you like ativan and
xanax and just keep monitoring take your
vitals ten times a day
after six days they release you i stay
there for a 30 day rehab program um
it's outpatient i go home every night
but it's like school i took eight weeks
off of work for this whole thing took a
big vacation
we did there 30 40 days
chip out you start to do that learn aaa
which
i like aaa i don't like the 12-step
program because i hid my drinking from
everybody i literally wrote an email the
night before i went in and said hey guys
this is what's been going on
like a coward hit send close the
computer check myself in it's like all i
need from you guys support and
everyone's like we didn't even we
thought you didn't even like alcohol
like i don't i just use it as a medicine
you know when you go there and you hear
alcoholics and addicts tell their
stories like
man that johnny would love johnny i
can't you know i can't see myself ever
not drinking ever again i'm like i can
i
you know
and like pill addicts and opiates i tell
them what my reaction is but they're
like
i re they would react the same way to me
that's what blew me away when they would
tell me yeah me too me too i'm like
that's your body telling you not to do
that [ __ ] they're like nah it's
something they're talking about you
could do more
like 30 percocets
i would die
me too
i watched my cousin take two one time
and i was like you're taking two you
know
oh yeah i i can't [ __ ] with that it's so
bad for me um
but yeah it's it's it's been i've been
sober for about a year good for you man
yeah i appreciate that uh i i got like
finally sober right during those last
couple of prioritisms and that was like
am i saying it wrong the whole time
democracy tomato tomorrow tomato
every doc i've heard it different from
different even urologists let me let me
ask you some questions let's go back to
your dick here
uh
how long in the clear are we now how
many months has it been since you
haven't had any issues
uh june of last year june of 2020. all
right have you had sex
since the june of 2020 since your last
no i have not
have not sex but i've i've it works you
jerk it oh yeah yeah and it works fine
yeah i mean there's no pain
no not at all oh anxiety of like oh my
god if i get this thing up it's never
gonna go down
the first couple of months i was scared
but the farther out you get and it's not
that so i don't even have the long ones
that last until noon anymore this thing
that he did
like
opened up the gates to allow more blood
in and out at all times i have a little
star mental and you think that this is
going to be something that that moves
forward like a procedure that yeah yeah
so there's there's two sides on the
inside and they start with
clearing out one side and
if that works they don't even have to
touch the left side of your desk it just
like works for me yeah yeah
um the only visible scar
um
[Music]
you have to look close
let's let's see it
[Laughter]
i've seen a video of joey diaz standing
up and showing his balls on camera like
joe rogan i'm not doing that here i'm
sorry
uh because it's it's not like smooth
like the skin on your face you know nuts
wrinkly yeah like rhino skin
yeah exactly so you can't really see it
um the only outward thing that makes me
self-conscious uh when i finally put
myself back into the dating pool is a
little bit of scar tissue at the bottom
like if you if you push pat like right
like way down where it connects to your
body there's like a little bit of a lump
and it only is visible when i have an
erection because the blood fills it up
and pushes that little bit of scar
tissue out
otherwise if i'm just you see me in the
locker room nobody would know anything
that ever happened to me
knock on wood
listen you've had
five surgeries for priapism
you've what surgery but 50 needles every
other time
so you've had you've had five procedures
hundreds of needles in your dick for
priapism what would be your advice to
anyone out there who
whether they're taking ed or not what is
your number one bit of advice
they're not exaggerating when they say
four or five hours go see a doctor
because
it's
i would go blind i'll go deaf i'll cut
off my hands before i want to lose that
so get that is gone
and then get to the doctors what you're
saying exactly ah that's like reading
here after you go after you go your
third or fourth round and you're on hour
three you know
if you
people think that taking
viagra or cialis or something like that
improves your performance it does not
yeah that does
it inhibits it because you're in pain
and [ __ ] who's you know yeah i mean but
again i'm gonna [ __ ] through that pain
you know what i'm saying i'm gonna give
you my a game i don't bring my b game or
my scene after after hour two of
thrusting you don't think it's gonna
feel like an indian red burn on your
dick oh god
nobody's [ __ ] that entire time i've
never [ __ ] for two hours straight my
whole life man not not straight not
straight even when i was young i take
breaks but not straight god damn all
night but take breaks
whoa it's insane man there's there's
i could do part two with you i mean yeah
we're good i mean unless you get another
one part two we can do but man we're
gonna put your picture on the post we'll
cover it up go ahead you want to say
something oh no if i get another one we
can do play-by-play live just like this
god's sake man i'm i'll be at the
hospital with wi-fi like check this [ __ ]
out man
it's something i don't ever want to get
used to and you sounded like you started
to get used to it and [ __ ] that i want
to just say that all this time later i
can look back at the trauma and laugh at
it that's how i process it much like you
and others yeah that's what it's all
about
i i if i sit and just take pity on
myself and you know why did this happen
to me like it's done don't also you
could have stayed drinking you could
have stayed on those pills you could
allow it to you know take you in any
direction you wanted to and
instead you just got your dicks your
dick fixed them now sounds like you're
trying to get your life back on track
and it's going good for you so good for
you dude yeah thanks man just just like
you and so many of your other guests on
the honeydew and honeydew everybody
get into therapy i don't care if you
think your life is awesome just like you
do a physical health check once twice a
year there's nothing wrong with going to
see a psychiatrist or a therapist no and
let me tell you this too don't feel the
pressure of having to go
you know like never stop going that's
great if you can but there are times
where i've had therapists go look man
you're in a really good place take a
break go out there apply the things
we've talked about to your life and see
how it goes you know you need to go back
you go back you can check in it's all
right you don't have to it's not a
marriage it doesn't have to be a
marriage it can be an open marriage
you're allowed to see different
therapists different types of therapy
are good for you so yeah man that's
that's all good uh michael farahani did
i say it right
yeah i'm sure we went long no we didn't
unintended we're coming up late in an
hour it's perfect man thank you very
much for coming on and thanks for having
me jesus jesus christ i don't know if i
i don't
i don't know i'll never see that thing
never unsee that goddamn
i regret opening my [ __ ] phone and
seeing that
uh but anyway brother thank you so much
for coming on and sharing your story
thank you um and thank you all thank you
all for building this community bigger
and better every month um again you're
getting the honeydew with you or excuse
me you're getting the honeydew on the
honeydew with you all patreon a day
early ad-free at no additional cost so
if you're thinking about sticking around
and you sign up for a a year you get a
month free plus the honeydew a day early
every week all right um thank you all
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
and if you or someone you know
absolutely has that story that has to be
heard please submit it at
honeydewpodcast gmail.com and hopefully
we can get to do a story with you all
until then talk to you all next week
[Music]
you